it's a new year with new possibilities
but one thing hasn't changed
Briggs it is still a shambles in fact if
anything has changed as the Coptics of
March 29th things have gotten worse
with Theresa May deciding to try and
play Russian roulette with the country's
future
the Prime Minister is attempting to
force Parliament to acquiesce to the
terms of her bad deal even though her
overtures to the EU for extra assurances
in time for next week's meaningful vote
have proved futile still with all this
she hasn't offered any alternative
options to her deal her message is clear
it's either her Deal or No Deal
this I fear is a losing hand for mrs.
May as masterfully demonstrated by
Yvette Cooper and Dominic Greaves
amendments this week last week channel 4
aired its dramatization of the
referendum campaign I was the I lost
interest when I learned that neither
Naomi Harris were Michaela Cole and Bill
Carson played me anyway I digress as the
drama depicted just as the Doomsday
threats failed for the remain campaign
they will fail for mrs. May I've got a
new mantra that I'm gonna be repeating
we can week cohesion courage and
competence okay I I made that three
series I think that what we've failed
from right from day one when we've had
this is referendum we should have come
together collectively to worry your
remains and break the tears yeah
collectively how do we navigate through
this how do we as a stop trying to stop
trying to make it into a personal point
scoring exercise or a posturing thing
over here but actually come together
with the objective of delivering bricks
at which we voted for that's the first
thing because when no one's worked
together in any way shape or form people
have used this process to further their
own personal agendas and it's been
terrible I think we've had practically
zero competence that every single twist
and turn and practically zero courage I
think we started this process on the
back for almost begging that
you to be our friends and and work with
us we should have had courage in our own
believes in our own strength and
actually negotiated from a front foot
position so that for me has been the
three failings and I do not think in any
way shape or form that is gonna change
anytime soon
I don't even know I wish I could sit
here with a intelligent succinct answer
and predict what I think is going to
happen imminently I don't know what is
gonna happen it's an absolute mess
two seconds now bring you in just to
come back on your point in terms of the
cohesion part well I think she tried
that for making sure that the people
that were the outward facing
representatives of the government were
break for tears
and they didn't want to be united with
the remainders in the cabinet so I think
she tried that in terms of what was the
second one
Kohi great courage well I think she's
been courageous she's been wrong but
she's been courageous nine billion
before we've even competent
accomplishes again the breaks of tears
were in charge of trying to deliver a
brexit package and they all jump ship
well
Ashlin well I said I know what's gonna
happen I was going to say Tory in
fighting yes what I felt was nothing
from your analysis Michelle is that this
happened because it's a war within the
conservative father you get from the
reason we've had a reference the reason
we have urosepsis and the reason we had
a referendum the reason this is a
shambles so the idea that it could kind
of happen in this you know you define
yeah I weigh lightly in fighting just
said Ettore past no but it was just live
holes later as well
yes whole Genesis is a wall within the
party that is currently running the
shambles that is still at war with
itself and you know as I've said this on
this program before at the apocalypse
there will be cockroaches and Tories
backstabbing each other because that
she's right it's not just the toys I
mean we're in the same where is the need
of the labor ecology been in this whole
thing good question remarkably quiet
yeah remarkably cuz we all know he's a
break city yeah and we all know his
party yeah remains yeah it's a bit
fundamental issue
I mean what's amazing is but you know
this time next week we could well be
going nowhere
unless the truth is maybe we'll be going
nowhere and you know what everybody
thinks if you were mrs. May and you lose
chance of losing the vote yeah if you've
lost the vote next Tuesday what does she
do change it don't you think it depends
by how much she loses no no no no if you
can't get the suit she can't get it sue
I would be tempted if I was her to call
her to try and call a general election
because you might win
she might because you want your
predictions to come well because if she
called a general election and won and
she would if I was a big city which I'm
not if I was a big deal I'd take her
deal I mean you'd take a deal yeah can I
say I had a chat with Carol at our
Christmas dinner and it's not often that
I agree with Carol Malone but she said
as a brexit to you and we know that is
what she definitely is that actually
given the choice of her deal or remains
she'll keep with what we've got with the
permission with your permission I want
to take a slightly off the way your main
thrust and examine the what we've seen
with the Speaker of the House wonderful
Patriot okay which i think is an
extraordinary turn because at one point
hopefully the electorate were running
this I the referendum and then it went
to our elected representatives and I I
kind of got that and the person who is a
prime minister who did albeit win just a
general now effectively the whole
process is controlled by one man Speaker
John Burke who in who ignored both
precedent yes and legal advice
and allowing an amendment from Dominic
grieve which just to remind the viewers
in the event of their being vote against
the prime minister had 21 days in which
to come back and say well now it's
reduced to 3 I love speaker no because
if you have no precedent that's one
thing if you then seek legal advice from
your clerks and it is reported you ball
out one of your clients it is reported
or certainly you we know you ignore all
the advice
so you freelancer no you just hence why
they will report crisp income a
Conservative MP the referee is no longer
neutral and that's a fact well and I
think that's one of the most damaging
there's an argument against that which
is an Margaret Beckett who used to be
leaving your house who's making this on
the radio this well I thought very said
yeah that's fine except this government
has done its best to make sure the
Parliament doesn't have a the speaker's
done this said I'm gonna let Parliament
yeah not the executive speaker is not
supposed to be neutral on the question
of parliamentary sovereignty noble and
this entire movement towards brexit is
supposed to be about wrestling control
back the advice to now to allow a vote
not allowed so Peter bone who is a but
just remind the viewers who is
appropriate he asked to put in an
amendment and he was told you can't put
in amendments John Bercow said oh but I
will take Dominic Greene and that's a
remain that's not fair well sorry dude
that's not fair
I'll take your but forget about what the
amendment said in the end what it showed
is that they are going to lose on a
whole
but that in the spirit of respect
equality with what Nick saying that if
you either you're either gonna hurt you
either going to allow amendments or
you're not you can't then go all these
ones okay you can't but you can
you can't put your car that's not fair
though is it going on but that's not
fair is it very annoyed by the way the
government will do this whole thing all
these truncated these amendments try
these two truncated and that's what we
need to do cuz if we don't do something
we're gonna crash our bodies yeah and
the bigger issue is the fact that
actually the legislature has more votes
than the executive that's the issue the
fact that she lost the vote is what we
should be bothered but you two is out
resident breaks it tears I mean if the
choice now is crash out but it's not but
it's leave without a deal would you
leave without a deal would I live with
that I wouldn't seek to do that but yeah
I think we'd have to you would you well
I think that we've been backed into a
corner this whole what I would I leave
without a deal yeah if you happen to I
think you but we should never sold stop
all medicines drenching the reason why I
think that the language of crashing out
is not as unfair as you make out is
because this isn't what was on offer
during the referendum when people
offered a vote for brexit they weren't
told boat for a No Deal scenario where
the future of our medicines transport
our British people
future of Scotland which may now vote to
leave if we go without a deal no one
ever said this is what we're offering
you so when we say crash out we're
talking about leaving in terms that were
never conceived or discussed as well
exit but I didn't vote for this shambles
and I feel very let down well there's a
raft of leading businessmen including
Lord Bamford who's a three point one
billionaire who says there will not be a
problem he sells 78% of his JCB Dyson
James I'm going to restore some sorta
question or some sanity because